the other big story was two sundays ago
i'm watching 60 minutes and i'm thinking
this is going to be a salute to ron
desantis i mean what he's done
bucking the system instead it looked to
be a hatchet job
and they went after you but by monday
morning it started to blow back in their
face because they were missing this
thing called
context and they took you out of context
and it caused a lot of controversial by
wednesday they're running for the hills
but they never apologized in 60 minutes
but they did do
a viewer response to your segment here's
a little of it with the reporter
sharon alfonsey listen
in the mail this week comments on our
story about disparities in the
distribution of covet 19 vaccine
in palm beach county florida viewers
focused on an exchange with florida
governor ron desantis at a press
conference
some viewers including a retired newsman
applauded the story
but many more comments condemned our
editing and reporting
then there was this i've watched 60
minutes for decades
after your biased piece on governor
desantis i will only watch it one more
time
just to see if you broadcast this
message
is that an apology
of course not and they've issued a lot
of mealy mouth statements
since the episode aired you know they
knew what they were putting on the air
was false and that that's the problem
that they have
because they they talk to the people
they refuse to put those key people on
the air
who were explaining everything that
happened of course they edited my
explanation
out uh and not give their viewers that
and so they they know that they got
caught so they've never even addressed
that
they just issue these mealy-mouth
statements but i would say to 60 minutes
is
in the american people they have so much
contempt
for their viewers to try to gaslight
them like this
you know what admit that it was false
that's the responsible thing to do but i
think folks like this these are
corporate media operatives basically you
know they had a political mission to
smear me
uh they thought that they could do it
drive by and just go on to the next
target
but i have a platform i have the ability
to fight back we have done that we're
going to continue to do that
but man how much contempt do they have
for their
fellow americans that really bugs me
well it wasn't only false it wasn't even
fair i mean she presented as if
you she asked you a question and you
never answered her you were just
you know uh talking back to her but you
gave her a two-minute answer and rather
than
encapsulate it uh you went into a
granular fashion and explained the whole
thing
they didn't touch that at all and then
cbs the next day said
well we edited for clarity what was
clear
is they just didn't like your point of
view democratic mayor in palm beach even
defended you
exactly ainsley you not everything i
said
is verified by everybody else who was
involved with this
the democratic mayor of palm beach
county our emergency management director
who's also a democrat
from south florida because what i said
is just what happened what they said is
just what happened
so the responsible thing would have been
to just simply not even air it
because obviously you don't have a story
here but instead
they wanted to do the smear so they took
all the evidence
and just left it on the cutting room
floor and continued
and launched a really um irresponsible
charge
so that is exactly what you don't do and
it's really rare that you catch them
this red-handed
where they're intentional where they're
reckless where they're trying to do this
you're doing a great job down there they
don't want that to happen
you're a republican and there's a chance
you could run for president and they
don't want that narrative they don't
want that positive narrative out there